J'peux savoir ce que tu fais sur mon ordinateur
?
-Je regarde un extrait de 1789, les Amants
de la Bastille, c'est une sorte d'uchronie
où des gens veulent renverser le pouvoir,
et pour ça il faut qu'ils prennent un bâtiment
super important qui s'appelle la Bastille,
va savoir pourquoi pour eux c'est LA chose
à faire, et à partir de là ils font la
Révolution Française.
Oui je sais, c'est complètement surréaliste.
D'ailleurs on en est à quel roi de nos jours,
Charles XIII ?
-Ok, on a du retard à rattraper.
Bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
de Chroniques de Prof, troisième du nom,
où nous allons revenir sur la Révolution
Française, ce que vous savez, ce que vous
pensez savoir, et ce que vous ignorez comme
cette jeune fille qui en ignorait moults détails.
T'as une remarque à faire avant de commencer
?
-Ils ont pas tué le roi.
Ils ont pas tué
le roi.
-Si, ils l'ont fait, mais tout ça fait partie
d'un processus complexe que nous allons expliquer
ensemble.
Et tout d'abord, pour en revenir à ce que
tu me disais avant
le générique, si je te dis "Révolution
Française", qu'est-ce
que ça t'évoque ?
-Barbarie !
-Fais un effort...
-Prise de la Bastille ?
-Très bien !
Eh bien sache que cet événement, dont tout
le monde se rappelle, n'est pas très important.
-Mais, pourtant on en a fait une comédie
musicale !
-On a d'abord dit que prendre la Bastille
a servi à libérer les prisonniers honteusement
enfermés là.
Mai ils n'étaient que 7 à l'époque, ils
étaient tellement peu nombreux que les révolutionnaires
sont allés inventer un prisonnier supplémentaire.
On a aussi considéré que la prise de la
Bastille était un symbole, c'était la destruction
du pouvoir arbitraire du roi, la fin de son
pouvoir d'enfermer les innocents par sa seule
volonté, un acte de rébellion du peuple
souverain contre le despotisme sombre de...
-Oui bah accouche, c'était quoi alors ?
-Il y avait de la poudre dans la Bastille,
les émeutiers avaient chopé des armes dans
les casernes des environs mais ils n'avaient
pas de poudre alors ils sont allés se servir
là où il y en avait.
Point.
Ils ont voulu s'armer parce que le roi avait
fait venir des troupes autour de Paris, ce
qui a fait peur aux parisiens.La révolution
avait déjà commencé avant le 14 juillet
sur le plan politique, et elle continue bien
après.
C'est donc tout pour la Bastille, on est venus,
on l'a vue, on n'en parlera plus.
-Oui mais c'est quand même devenu un symbole
pour la France, j'ai vu que c'était devenu
la journée nationale !
-Et même ça c'est faux ! Le 14 juillet ne
commémore pas la prise de la Bastille, du
14 juillet 1789, mais la Fête de la Fédération,
du 14 juillet 1790.
Au lieu de célébrer un événement violent
et sans grand intérêt sur le plan politique,
on commémore une fête célébrant l'unité
de la nation, ce qui a un peu plus de sens
même si tout le monde l'a oublié.
Revenons maintenant aux origines de cette
révolution, partie 1, les causes ! Eh bien
c'est la crise, mon bon monsieur, pour plusieurs
raisons.
D'abord l'idée d'un roi concentrant tous
les pouvoirs commence à être montrée du
doigt, notamment par les philosophes des Lumières
qui sont entendus par une partie de la population.
Pas dans les campagnes, mais dans la bourgeoisie
des villes.
J'y vais, hein !
Qu'on lui coupe la tête !
-Il a le droit.
J'y vais, hein !
Qu'on lui coupe la têt...AAaaaaaah !
-Vive le despotisme éclairé !
La France traverse également une crise économique
que les ministres successifs n'arrivent pas
à régler.
Et c'est justement pour discuter d'une réforme
fiscale qui ne passe pas que le roi décide
finalement de convoquer les Etats Généraux,
une sorte d'assemblée réunissant les trois
ordres.
A notre gauche nous avons la noblesse, ordre
ancien et prestigieux, dans lequel on ne rentre
que s on a reçu une invitation et qui peut
se payer un appart en plein centre de Paris
sans même payer d'impôts.
A votre droite, le clergé, indispensable
pour le salut de vos âmes, il vous prélève
des fortunes mais il vous le rend bien.
Et au milieu, ben...
Tout le reste.
Le tiers-Etat.
Ça .
Les Etats Généraux se réunissent donc,
après que les différents villages et corps
de métier aient rédigé des cahiers de doléances
dans lesquels ils expriment toutes leurs revendications.
"Cher Louis XVI.
Comme j'ai été sage cette année, je voudrais
pouvoir manger à ma faim tous les jours.
Je voudrais aussi ne plus être écrasée
sous une charge d'impôts aberrante.
J'aimerais que tu arrêtes d'enfermer des
gens sans même qu'ils soient jugés, que
la paix règne dans le monde, et que tous
les citoyens soient libres et heureux."
Ah, c'est beau...
Nous arrivons maintenant aux événements.
Les Etats Généraux prennent rapidement une
tournure que n'avait pas prévu Louis XVI:
en effet les trois ordres étaient séparés
pour délibérer, ce qui ne convient pas au
tiers-Etat qui décide d'inviter la noblesse
et le clergé à les rejoindre.
Ce que certains acceptent en voyant qu'il
y a plus d'ambiance chez le tiers-Etat.
Ensuite ils décident de rédiger une Constitution
pour la France, et ça, c'est une révolution
! Nous sommes le 17 juin 1789, et c'est le
début de la fin pour Louis XVI.
On entend souvent parler du serment du jeu
de Paume, rendu célèbre par un tableau de
David.
En fait en voyant les députés se mettre
à faire tout sauf ce qui était prévu, Louis
XVI a un plan machiavélique: il fait fermer
la salle dans laquelle se réunissaient les
députés.
J'ai mis un cadenas sur la porte, la révolution
est finie, mouahahahaha !
Du coup les députés se réunissent dans
la première salle qu'ils trouvent, le court
de tennis local, et jurent qu'ils resteront
ensemble jusqu'au bout.
-Heureusement qu'on jouait pas à la crapette
dans cette salle, ça aurait été moins classe
!
Dans la nuit du 4 au 5 août, les députés,
qui sont maintenant des membres des trois
ordres, organisent une grande soirée dans
laquelle c'est à celui qui piétinera le
plus les institutions dans lesquelles il a
grandi.Je parle bien sûr de l'abolition des
privilèges, un grand moment de l'histoire
de France, où les membres de la noblesse
et du clergé s'expriment tour à tour pour
mettre fin à leurs privilèges.
Cependant dans l'euphorie ils se mettent à
rejeter leurs privilèges à tord et à travers,
si bien que le lendemain certains essaient
de revenir sur leurs décisions.
Malheureusement pour eux, heureusement pour
nous, ça ne passe pas.
Et j'abolis les banalités !
-Ouaiiiis !
Et j'abolis le droit de cuissage !
-Bouuuh
-Regarde l'épisode 2, ignorant !
Mais...
Que font ces paysans dans mes bois ?
-Ben on chasse, vous avez aboli les droits
seigneuriaux.
-Fallait pas picoler comme ça !
-Vous encore ça va, y'en a qui se sont réveillés
Sans Culottes.
Par la suite les députés continuent de faire
leur travail de député.
Non, leur vrai travail.
Ils rédigent la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme et du Citoyen, un préambule à la
constitution, inspiré du Human Rights anglais
et de la Déclaration d'Indépendance américaine.
Rendue célèbre par un grand acteur américain,
Nicolas Cage...
-Raconte la suite, nom de Dieu !
-Bon, après ça ils rédigent la Constitution,
et comme elle s'appelle la Constitution de
1791 je vous laisse calculer combien de temps
elle met à être finalisée.
Entre-temps, le roi a tenté de s'éclipser,
en vain.
Lors de la fuite de Varennes le 20 juin 1791,
Louis XVI quitte Paris où il était sous
bonne garde avec sa famille afin de rejoindre
l'est de la France où se trouvent des troupes
prêtes à organiser une contre-révolution.
Malheureusement pour lui, certains des partisans
de Louis XVI qui sont disséminés le long
du trajet sont pour le moins incompétents,
et le voyage prend du retard.
A Paris Lafayette, qui avait la garde du roi,
envoie des hommes à sa recherche et fait
croire au peuple que le roi a été enlevé,
afin de ne pas diffuser le vrai message que
Louis XVI voulait faire passer aux français.
Et que vous pouvez retrouver en cliquant sur
ce lien.
En chemin la compagnie est reconnue par plusieurs
personnes, et c'est à Varennes qu'ils sont
finalement arrêtés et ramenés à Paris
sous les huées de la foule.
La fuite du roi aurait pu être catastrophique
pour la république si elle avait eu l'effet
escompté, mais au final elle contribue à
répandre l'idée qu'on pourrait se passer
d'un roi pour gouverner.
Par la suite certaines nations voient d'un
mauvais oeil ce qui se passe en France, la
monarchie étant profondément ancrée en
Europe.
A partir de 1792, la France est donc en guerre
contre le Saint-Empire Germanique, le royaume
Anglo-Corse, le royaume de Grande-Bretagne,
le royaume de Prusse, le royaume de Naples,
le royaume de Sicile, le royaume de Sardaigne,
l'empire Russe, le royaume du Portugal, les
Provinces-Unies, le grand duché de Toscane,
le duché de Modène, le duché de Parme,
la république de Venise, le royaume de Suède,
le royaume d'Espagne, l'empire Ottoman et
certains royalistes français comme les Vendéens
et les Chouans.
-Et ils ont des alliés dans tout ça ?
-Bien sûr, ils comptent dans leurs rangs
la Norvège, les Irlandais unis, le...
-Ok, la suite.
-La France parvient tout de même à s'en
sortir et y gagne même quelques territoires
lors du traité d'Amiens de 1802.
Pour revenir à la Révolution, l'idée de
la république suit son cours à partir de
la fuite de Varennes.
D'autant que le roi passe son temps à opposer
son droit de veto aux propositions de loi
de l'Assemblée, et on le soupçonne de s'allier
aux monarchies ennemies afin de reprendre
le pouvoir en France.
La monarchie est donc suspendue le 10 août
1792, et la république s'installe progressivement
en France à partir de septembre.
C'est aussi à cette période qu'on commence
à utiliser le calendrier républicain, qui
reste en France jusque 1806.
Il reprend des noms liés à la nature comme
Floréal, Germinal, Viandhalal...
-Une minute, s'il vous plaît !
-C'est qui ça ?
-Je suis un Sans Culotte, et avant que vous
me sortiez vos blagues paillardes à deux
assignats je tiens à préciser qu'on m'appelle
comme ça parce que je ne porte pas ce genre
d'atour.
Communément appelé la culotte.
Pour la simple raison que c'est totalement
has been.
Je suis surtout un révolutionnaire militant
et engagé, et j'aimerais savoir ce que vous
pensez faire de ce type, là, parce que c'est
très bien d'avoir fondé une république,
mais il faudrait prendre une décision: on
le met à la retraite ou on l'exécute ?
-La retraite !
-On le condamne à mort, c'est un symbole
de l'Ancien Régime, qui doit disparaître
pour que la République s'installe.
-Mais c'est un être humain...
-Grâce à cette habile mise en scène, vous
avez un aperçu des débats qui ont agité
l'Assemblée lors du procès de Louis XVI.
Et à une petite majorité, le verdict est...
-La mort de Louis XVI, qui est exécuté le
21 janvier 1793.
[pleure]
La constitution de 1791 n'est plus valable
puisqu'elle correspondait à une monarchie
constitutionnelle, et le roi n'est...
Plus fonctionnel.
On rédige donc une nouvelle constitution.
La Constitution de 1793, qui déchire sa maman
parce qu'elle est super démocratique: on
abolit l'esclavage, on accorde le suffrage
universel, vous voulez des droits sociaux
? On vous donne des droits sociaux.
-Vive la France !
-T'emballe pas, elle n'est jamais appliquée.
La guerre continue, la France est en crise,
on décide donc d'instaurer un gouvernement
révolutionnaire provisoire jusqu'à ce que
les choses se calment.
On entre alors dans la phase la moins glorieuse
de la Révolution, celle où les députés
ont tellement peur des ennemis de la République
qu'ils déclarent suspectes de plus en plus
de personnes selon des conditions parfois
farfelues.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la période de la Terreur,
et une fois déclaré suspect vous êtes conduit
au tribunal révolutionnaire qui peut soit
vous acquitter, soit vous exécuter.
-Au moins ils sont jugés équitablement !
-A partir de juin 1794, le seul verdict possible
est l'exécution.
-Ah.
Efficace, le tribunal.
-Pour être déclaré suspect, rien de plus
simple ! Il vous suffit de ne pas avoir l'air
très républicain, de ne pas avoir de cocarde
tricolore, de ne pas porter sur vous votre
carte civique ou d'être dénoncé par un
témoin qui peut être votre voisin, votre
pire ennemi, ou un inconnu croisé dans la
rue.
Vous avez donc énormément de possibilités
si vous voulez faire partie des quelques dizaines
de milliers de personnes victimes de cette
période !
Bref, tout part en cacahuète quand les grandes
figures de la Révolution se mettent à s'accuser
à leur tour les unes les autres.
Et lorsqu'il ne reste que Robespierre comme
figure emblématique de la Terreur, il est
à son tour arrêté, exécuté, et la Terreur
prend fin peu à peu à partir de là.
On entre alors dans la phase pépère de la
Révolution, le Directoire, on rédige une
nouvelle constitution...
La jeune république connaît encore de nombreuses
péripéties avec le coup d'Etat de Napoléon,
la restauration de la monarchie...
Mais ça, c'est une autre histoire !
-C'était plutôt intéressant.
-Merci, j'aime bien cette période aussi,
il se passe tellement de choses...
-Mais du coup si j'ai bien suivi, la prise
de la Bastille montre un ralliement populaire
à la Révolution qui était au départ simplement
l'oeuvre de députés.
C'est vachement important !
-Euh...
Oui, c'est pas faux.
Rendez-vous le mois prochain !